New York Times forced to make a major
correction after publishing a story
implying UN Ambassador nikki Haley
dropped over 52 grand on curtains here's
the original headline Nikki Haley's view
of New York is priceless her curtains 52
thousand seven hundred and one dollars
turns out though nikki Haley had
absolutely nothing to do with it the
curtains were bought by the Obama
administration unbelievable
smear mischaracterization Dana and they
corrected it to be fair but and they
corrected it within the same day right
so it's that they didn't even wait till
tomorrow although I hope that it will be
in the paper that's because they got
hammered all day for this and when they
do the correction in the paper it's
gonna be a really small write down at
the corner thankfully though social
media it's gotten all around and it made
its own segment on the 5:00 in the
middle of hurricane coverage one of the
things about media bias that I've
complained about I don't like to
complain about media bias all the time I
think it's a little bit of a weak thing
but that conservatives can make
arguments that win on the merits but the
media will often do subtle digs and
constant digs with headlines photographs
and captions mm-hmm and especially if
you'll see like pictures if they did for
example President Obama has never taken
a bad picture I've never seen a bad
picture of President Obama you can find
plenty of bad pictures of Republicans
right I think Obama's pictures with the
halo in the background very majestic but
President Trump has some pretty good he
can't take a bad picture absolutely not
of course not but if he did it would be
in the New York Times Greg it said the
apartment that she's in is fifty two
thousand dollars a month about the same
as your apartment here in Manhattan it's
pretty nice yeah pretty nice no way
fifty two thousand a month for the
apartment the nikki Haley is in but it
has majestic views of the city and she
has to entertain I need security but I
think the frost of the article was
before they got caught was Nikki's
living large off the taxpayer and the
State Department's slashing the budget
and shutting down programs but they got
caught I would like to say it is
curtains for the New York Times this is
actually worse than a mistake because or
a lie
because it's intentionally misleading
right the in the story was six Perigord
laughs down I don't know if that's there
intentionally maybe they just let me
finish it was in it was in the pit was
in the article it was in the article
that Obama had ordered the curtains so
the story was framed in a certain way
that was misleading as if it was Nikki
Haley's choice of the head so they
somebody had written read the story and
still put that headline so that it's
pretty scummy what they did they knew
what they were doing we're wrong and the
only reason why they changed it is
because there are people who scream
media bias I mean it's it's media bias
may come off as weak sometimes but some
people have to say it or no one will
ever get called off as a criticism of
people who say media bias I just like I
think that there is some obvious stuff
like this I do think that there are
times when conservatives don't try to
make great arguments that they could
make big and just hide behind media and
Katie not only did the Obama
administration pay for these curtains
the New York Times quote in the Obama
administration is quoted on the record
slamming the Trump administration we're
cutting you know the budget at the State
Department and saying how can you pay
for a $50,000 customized kirtan system
for the ambassador to the UN it's like
you guys paid for it this was under John
Kerry where's the question about that
and The Times did issue a correction
however I don't think it actually was a
completely fair correction I think that
the entire story should have been
retracted because without nikki Haley in
the story there was it wasn't a story
and if you look at the language they use
in the be correction that they have as
you said that will be at the bottom of
the page
they say that they created an unfair
impression when really it was a
completely false allegation and as Greg
said they admit in the story multiple
times that this happened in 2016 and was
already paid for and so this idea that
they used her photo saying they
shouldn't have used her photo they're
sorry for that the entire story wouldn't
have existed if nikki Haley wasn't the
center of the story they should retract
the entire thing and rewrite it the most
revealing thing about the article and
about the allegation and about the smear
is you know what I grew up I grew up
around here so you grew up thinking that
the New York Times was
like the Bible but you know God's Word
you know yeah I did in my in my you know
maybe in your house in my house we did
in Hurricane Katrina there was a story
written that said that I pushed a rescue
worker out of the way so I could be
filmed saving a nun in a flooded
building then they I said that's a lie
you know it did never happen we showed
them all the video the outtakes and
everything else
the New York Times ultimately
reluctantly even after the editorial
refused to correct that the public
editor wrote a story that the revelation
that they work just as political as the
New York Post or any of the tabloids was
to me was like a rigged grill disabusing
Whitehall dough story is is probably
really most important is that you only
know about media bias until a story is
written about you like people people do
not understand what it is until you were
either interviewed or you were the
subject of a story and you go this is
not how it happened I swear this is not
how it happened
so you like there should be a book of
those stories of people that were not
just a book it could be a set yeah it's
a I was interviewed by the New York
Times this is how this is what it was
this is how it happened don't get me
started on Puerto Rico and how you know
all these people have died in the storm
of Puerto Rico that I covered for over
two weeks that I you know I a property
owner of Puerto Rico my father one of
seventeen children mm-hmm like they say
all these people died in the storm
seventy percent of the power was out
before the storm
so when did when did people start dying
when was it on you know Hurricane Maria
that the people started was it when the
power went I was there one time it was a
transformer of fire and the power went
out when they started dying then I mean
at what point do you recognize that what
they're doing is a political agenda
couched in the the nice language of
journalists do you I liked what he said
don't get me started
I have a short fuse